[MUSIC PLAYING]
KERRY MUNZ: Hi, everybody.
My name is Kerry Munz,
and I'm the director
of engineering for the
platform infrastructure
teams at HubSpot.
And I'm here to
tell you the tale
of going both multi-cloud and
multi-region for the first time
at HubSpot in Q1 of this year.
There are a few key lessons we
learned from this experience.
And the one that I
want you all to know
is that it can be done fast.
And the key to this is
treating your infrastructure
as dynamic as your
application code.
Your infrastructure is code.
So let's start briefly
with what is HubSpot?
HubSpot is the leading CRM
marketing sales and customer
experience platform.
We offer sales and marketing
automation software,
abd it helps companies attract
visitors, convert leads, close,
and delight customers.
We focus on small and
medium businesses.
We offer sale-- excuse me.
We help the small guys nurture
their customer relationships
as effectively as the big guys.
So this is where our journey
starts, with our CEO.
Brian Halligan is HubSpot CEO.
We were opening an
office in Berlin
to strengthen our commitment
to our EU customers.
And we needed to give
them better performance,
stronger security.
And Brian wanted
tighter integrations
with AdWords and G Suite.
And on top of all
that, he wanted
to offer more free
services to our customers.
As you all may know,
freemium is not free to host.
So we manage our infrastructure
costs very efficiently.
The million-dollar question
with any project is time.
We already had a
lot on our plate
with a big MySQL migration,
and we were a big migration
into Kubernetes.
And this added a ton more.
But we knew it was
important to our customers
and wanted to
support the business.
He told us this would be in Q1.
And he had come to us
in summer of last year.
So the time line was very short.
When he said Q1, I
imagined a fiery hellscape.
What I wanted to say
was, go F yourself.
But what I actually
said was, we got this.
So I went to our
infrastructure teams.
I told them that
we are on the hook
to support our EU customers.
They came up with a few options.
They said we could consider
expanding with AWS.
We could consider spinning
up our own data center.
Or we could consider
a new cloud provider.
So in the end, we went
with Google Cloud.
So the rest of this tale is to
show you why that was not scary
with our foundation of tooling,
how we tested our biggest
fears fast, and
how we uncovered 11
years of unknown
dependencies lurking
in our infrastructure to
successfully ship a new EU data
center in Q1.
So HubSpot's best-kept secret
is our amazing platform
infrastructure teams.
These 14 teams have the mission
to make our 60 other product
teams as effective and
efficient as possible,
basically to give
them superpowers,
to improve the reliability and
efficiency of our platform,
and to keep the
free in freemium.
The foundation of all of this
is that everything at HubSpot
is code.
Have you all ever
heard the expression
of pets versus cattle
referring to your servers?
So pets are the
ones that you baby.
You take care of them because
they are mission critical
and they are replaceable.
So they can destroy your
business if they die.
Cattle are all identical.
You can shoot one in the
head, and another one
will take its place.
At HubSpot, we only have cattle.
No pets.
So our platform supports tooling
for our marketing, sales,
and services customers.
This runs on top of a giant
automation and analytics
platform that is
processing a ton of data--
data based on analytics,
ads, contacts, email, chat,
all sorts of things-- processing
data from all sorts of sources
on behalf of our customers.
So how do we manage
all of that big data?
There are many different
types of workflows
that are needed to make it
all work seamlessly together.
We have focused
largely on open source
because years ago the
cloud was not so mature,
and we needed the control
to be able to dig in
and tune our data
services as we needed.
We wanted to be able
to touch the code.
It was also because
of the need to be
able to control costs
to keep freemium free.
We actually have hundreds of
thousands of free customers,
so we run our infrastructure
with costs in mind.
And over the years we wrote
a lot of automation software
to keep our data infrastructure
running smoothly.
Since scale can mean many things
to different companies here,
I want to give you
some quick numbers
to get a sense of what it meant
when we said we were going
multi-cloud and multi-region.
So HBase is the heart
of HubSpot data.
Our HBase clusters
are processing up
to 90 million
requests per second
and processing nearly
half a petabyte a day.
Kafka is HubSpot's bloodstream.
With Kafka, we are handling
around a million requests
per second.
Elasticsearch is
our nerve system,
supporting nearly half
a billion documents.
The bane of my
existence is MySQL.
We actually have more
than 500 MySQL clusters.
And at HubSpot, they
grow like mushrooms.
I think our engineers
can't tell the difference
between a database and a table.
So that totals more than
1,300 individual VMs.
And we have historically had
one person managing all of them.
He knew them all personally.
Essentially, he had 500 pets.
And there were far too
many manual operations
to tend to them all.
So early last year,
we decided to change
all of that, which
was lucky, considering
the move we were going to
need to the EU data center
later in the year.
We needed to orchestrate
the life cycles of those 500
clusters.
And at the same time, a lot
of our relational-style data
was too big.
And we needed to move
a lot of that data
into HBase to be able to
support the request load.
We chose Vitess and Kubernetes
to solve this problem for us.
Vitess is an open
source clustering system
to automate horizontal
scaling of MySQL,
and it was created
by the YouTube team.
We've become very active
contributors to this project.
It essentially is a
proxy to SQL queries.
It makes sharding very simple
to support horizontal scaling
in an easy way.
It also replaced our
manual and Ansible
plays that we use
to handle things
like master slave failovers
when machines would fail.
We run Vitess inside
of Kubernetes.
We have years of
experience with Mesos
for orchestrating docker
containers and JVMs for running
our own applications.
And we were excited
to find a system
to orchestrate our data stores
as easily as our applications.
And we could share server
resources for those 1,300 VMs,
instead of relying on
dedicated machines.
So our Kubernetes migration
was already under way
when our CEO came to me.
So why did we consider Google?
We've been running HubSpot
in AWS for 10 years.
When Brian came to us and
said we needed to do better
by our EU customers and we
needed better integrations
with AdWords and
G Suite, we said
it was time to survey
the cloud landscape.
So BigTable is the
basis for HBase.
We've admired BigTable
performance numbers
for a long time.
We put a lot of
resources into HBase
and dreamed of a future
where Google would take care
of all those headaches for us.
Plus, if you've ever had a
visit from the Google team
or talked to the
BigTable engineers,
they will walk into
your conference room,
draw a picture
that looks exactly
like this on your whiteboard,
drop the microphone,
and just leave the room.
So we were interested
in knowing more.
We were also
interested in Google
because we are big fans
of their open source.
We have our own
internal commitment
to open source and have
published some tools,
like Blazar and Singularity,
I'll tell you about a little
later.
And we were already
actively contributing
to Vitess and Kubernetes.
Our infrastructure team
was also interested
in seeing what cool things they
could do using Google's network
offerings.
Plus, the timing was perfect.
Google was coming out with a
data center in Frankfurt in Q4.
So the big reason I
am here is to tell
this tale of the
foundation of our tools
and how that helped us
to move very quickly.
I want to point out
to you a few areas
that we needed to update to
be able to support a new cloud
provider and a new
region, and how
this could work for you too.
So first I'll give
you some details
about the components
that make up
our platform so you understand
what I'm talking about.
So right now, we are
running more than 3,000 VMs
in the cloud.
All of our infrastructure
tools interface
with our cloud providers
through a tool called Rainmaker.
Rainmaker is the foundation
of our infrastructure-as-code
approach.
It wraps all of the
cloud primitive,
like the API's a spin up, spin
up and down VMs, attach disks,
manage storage
buckets, do security
group management,
things like that.
We use Puppet to keep
the configuration for all
of our VMs consistent.
Puppet updates are
managed through GitHub.
And they're deployed like any
other app in our deployment
pipeline.
So the HubSpot
product is actually
made up of more than
6,000 microservices, jobs,
and tasks, all running on
top of Singularity in Mesos.
Singularity is our open source
app orchestration framework
that is powered by Apache Mesos.
We introduced Singularity into
our platform a few years ago
to remove the complexity of
running and deploying workloads
directly to machines.
It used to be that engineers
had to worry about everything
for their services and tasks.
They would worry
about horizontally
scaling those services.
They would worry about whether
the underlying hardware
was failing.
So Singularity let
engineers focus
on what they do best,
which is writing software,
instead of managing
infrastructure.
On top of our app
orchestration framework,
we have a highly
efficient CI/CD pipeline
to make it extremely
easy for our engineers
to build and deploy code fast.
We have over 2,000
active GitHub repos
for all of those
microservices and tasks.
We have actually archived
over 6,000 other repos
over the years, which is because
we are constantly experimenting
and improving how HubSpot runs.
So we wrote Blazar, our
build orchestration tool.
We used to run all of our
builds on Jenkins, but because
of the explosive growth
of our repos and branches,
it became too complex to manage.
The UI basically turned into
a hellscape for our engineers.
We addressed those
pains by building
Blazar around GitHub webhooks.
It automatically
detects new repos
and requires no
extra configuration
to know exactly what to build.
Blazar runs inside of
Singularity itself.
So last year, Blazar did more
than 2 and 1/2 million builds.
And this year, we are on
track to run more than 4
million builds.
We also wrote our own
deploy tool, called Orion.
Orion makes it simple
for our engineers
to deploy workloads
into Singularity
more than 10,000 times a week.
Last year, we in fact
deployed over 900,000 times
to both QA and prod.
And we put a heavy investment
into the user experience
for Orion because this tool is
so critical for our engineers
to get their work done.
It supports health checks,
acceptance tests, for example.
We also acknowledge
that engineers do not
write perfect code.
So we prioritize
mean time to repair,
making it simple to roll
back changes as well.
So now, back to our story
on how we expanded to the EU
with Google.
So to start a project like
this, an important question
any engineering leader's toolbox
is how can we keep it simple?
Since HubSpot is made up of
thousands of microservices
and jobs, making a fully
sharded version of HubSpot
in such a short amount of
time would be reckless.
And we were not reckless.
We were confident,
but not reckless.
So we started by
narrowing the focus.
We asked ourselves what was
the most important thing
for reliability and performance
for our customers in the EU.
We already have
approximately 70,000 websites
fronted by Cloudflare across
the globe for fast performance.
But any time data is submitted
by our customers' customers,
it goes back to our
origin in Virginia.
And if there are issues with
the network or any other issues
back at the origin,
that data could be lost.
So it was important
that we did not
miss collecting any usage data.
So we focused on analytics,
click tracking, CTAs,
and those sorts of
collection services.
So as I said
before, we have been
AWS customers for 10 years.
So the next most important
thing to figure out
was what did we
fear about Google?
So we made a list.
And there were, in
fact, three things.
Simply, could we deploy to GCP?
Would the network connection
between AWS and GCP
be fast enough?
And there was this thing
the Google team told us
about called live migrations.
So to start, the question was
could we simply deploy services
to GCP?
We wanted to make sure
our engineers didn't
need to care about the
details of running on Google
and also about running
in another region.
I mentioned Rainmaker earlier
as our VM management tool.
Back in 2012, VM management
was really hard to do.
So we had created
Rainmaker to abstract away
AWS console and primitives and
create one simple way to spin
up servers correctly.
So the thing that we created
six years ago to work better
with AWS became a key
factor in making it
easy to work with Google too.
So what we did was
we looked at the API
calls we needed to make Google
so we could start and stop
machines, set up disks,
configuring networking.
And this is just a matter
of refactoring our code
to create a second adapter.
The first adapter was to handle
the AWS primitives, and then
a second adapter for
Google primitives.
Rainmaker APIs all
stayed exactly the same.
So all of our automated
tooling stayed the same.
Then we updated the Rainmaker
UI, added Belgium as an option
because the
Frankfurt data center
didn't exist at that time,
and bam, we had Google.
Our second fear was
the network connection
between AWS and Google,
since our data is now going
to be crossing the Atlantic.
So we used the standard
cloud provider VPNs
to connect the two networks
together across the ocean,
and it was giving us
approximately 1 gigabit
per second and taking time
to ramp up to that speed.
To support HBase replication
and our Kafka streams,
we wanted to make
sure we could get
10 gigabits per second
throughput across the ocean.
And we wanted to treat our
European data center just
like any other availability
zone within Amazon.
So the way that
our team did that
was actually rather clever.
They noticed that they would
get 6 milliseconds of latency
between our data
center in Virginia
and Google's data
center in Virginia.
So we set up strongSwan, which
is an open source VPN tunnel,
to connect the
Virginia data centers.
Once the traffic
was inside Google,
it crossed the Atlantic on
Google's fast internal network
instead of over
the open internet.
And we were able to get the
performance that we needed.
The final thing that we
feared were live migrations.
And we really feared them.
Live migrations are
actually very clever.
When Google needs to
replace hardware or update
their hypervisor, they move your
VM from one piece of hardware
to another behind the scene.
When we first heard about this,
we thought it was really cool.
But then we were afraid of what
it was going to do to HBase.
So with HBase, we keep a strict
6 millisecond response time.
And this is important because
the HubSpot UI touches
many different services,
and those services touch
many other services.
So any delay in any request
can cause a cascading effect,
resulting in a slow
UI for our users.
So even though the difference
between a 6 millisecond
response time and a 10
millisecond response time
doesn't seem like
much, that makes
a difference between a slow and
snappy UI for our customers.
So the way live
migrations work is
Google takes a
snapshot of your VM
and starts an identical
copy on other hardware.
Then they pause the
original VM, copy over
anything that changed, and
then start up a new VM.
The Google folks told us that
this could take up to a second,
depending on how much RAM
was on the original VM
or how heavy the RAM churn was.
HBase is very right-intensive,
meaning the pause time
could end up being very long.
And that could be catastrophic
to the response time.
So to solve this, we spun up
an HBase cluster in Google.
We replayed production
workloads through that cluster,
had the Google engineers force
a bunch of live migrations,
and we watched our graphs
to see the effects.
We were shocked to see there
were no effects at all.
So at that point, our
three fears were gone.
So we committed to moving
forward with Google in the EU.
So now that our fears were
gone, what was the plan?
This was four steps.
Update Rainmaker.
Spin up the platform components.
Work out all the application
dependency issues.
And finally update our DNS
to send traffic to the EU.
So it took us five
days to update--
it took us five days to
set up our infrastructure
to deploy to Frankfurt.
We had to move from
Belgium to Frankfurt.
This involved setting up DNS
services, as well as Puppet.
Rainmaker was also really easy
to set up because we already
had the adapter for Google.
So it was simply
pointing to a new region.
Next was the bulk
of the work, where
we considered HubSpot really
multi-cloud and multi-region.
Our team spun up the
clusters we needed
to run our platform in Google,
including ZooKeeper, HBase,
LDAP, the Vault.
We had originally
hacked a deploy
option to Belgium
early on to get a proof
of concept for Orion
to deploy to Google in the EU.
So we rewrote it the right
way and deployed analytics
as our first test service.
We also got the product
engineering teams excited
and showed them
the simple way they
could configure their services
to run in both regions or just
one or the other.
So they started deploying
at that time too.
This took us 30
days to get right.
The product teams started
untangling their application
services at that time.
They figured out
what they needed
to run to support our data
collection services in the EU
independently, without
reaching back to the US.
We had quite a few
to work through
at that time and plenty of
skeletons in the closet.
Apart from spinning up clusters
and deploying services,
there was actually an
even bigger hurdle.
And this was the human
element of the project.
We have more than 60 small,
autonomous engineering teams.
They are in Dublin, Boston,
as well as remote teams.
With so many
microservices, we needed
to figure out the
dependencies and uncover
all of those skeletons
as fast as possible.
So this was the key question.
How do you get everyone to
find all of the skeletons?
So the way we did this was
with a month and a half
of weekly chaos testing.
We decided this was the
best way to get everyone
on the same page, to figure
out what we didn't know about,
and to move fast together.
So we got an engineer
from each product team
who owned a collection service,
along with the platform
engineers.
We bought them all lunch.
We dialed in the Dublin team.
And we broke the network.
So that first test, they
were all very confident
that everything
was going to work.
But there was a huge list
of things that broke.
Our goal was to cut
the network and be
able to restart all
of those services
and ensure that they
could survive completely
independently.
So we made a list.
And it was a very long list
of everything that had broken
and all of the missed
dependencies-- for example,
databases that were still
running in the US that needed
to be replicated, authentication
services, domain services
as well.
So we added those
teams to future tests.
And the list of what we
needed to fix was long.
But the teams all agreed
to fix them and come back
the next week.
So we did this each
week for six weeks.
And each week, the list
got shorter and shorter,
until there was no more list.
So we even came up
with some creative ways
to cause failures between
the two data centers
and tried those as well.
Until finally, it was all green.
And we were confident
we could run
in the EU data center completely
independent from the US.
The final step was to enable
Cloudflare [? GOD-based ?] DNS
for our production traffic.
That took a few days to roll
out because we did each service
one at a time to
make sure that there
were no disruptions
to our customers.
So the overall time line
was, in fact, longer than
the 30 days I promised in
the title of this talk.
But we were officially
multi-cloud and multi-region
with our platform
and one test service,
but just not fully
production-ready, in 30 days.
But a short seven weeks later,
we met our deadline with room
to spare.
So what was the result?
Today 9% of our VMs are
running in Google Cloud.
We saw a 5x speed-up in response
time for our European customers
due to SSL
terminating in Europe.
And 17% of our
collection requests
now are processed
on Google Cloud.
The EU was also spared
two service disruptions
when there were
network issues as well.
One funny thing that
happened during our testing
was a trans-Pacific network
cut during our tests.
So requests from Australia
were getting routed
to Europe instead of the US.
So we were getting a
similar unexpected boost
for our customers in
Australia at the same time.
So at the end of
Q1, we celebrated.
And the team has moved on
to their next big mission
after some great lessons
learned about going
multi-region and multi-cloud
at the same time.
So let's recap
those key takeaways.
List and test your fears
first and do this fast.
Keep it simple.
Do not bite off more than you
can chew with the first go.
There will be
plenty of unknowns.
Use chaos testing
as your best friend.
It is a great forcing function
to uncover those skeletons
and shed light on
what is not done.
Treat your
infrastructure as code.
Use abstractions to be able
to experiment and move fast.
And finally, don't
forget to use lunch
to coerce the human
side of the project.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]